So now we have the door working, the final thing that we need to do is create a button which can be used in order to lock or unlock the door.
This gives us an opportunity to look at communication between two different factors and how we might go about setting that up.
So let's create a new factor.
So to do that, I'm going to watch and click in the content browser and I'm going to come up and create a new blueprint class.
Again, I'm going to select from an actor and I'm going to call this BP underscore button.
I'm going to double click to open it up. Now in this, I want a couple of things, a couple of components.
I'm going to start with a static mesh, static mesh component.
I'm going to call this button mesh.
And in this, I'm going to search for corner and that should bring up the SM underscore corner frame.
So this is just a nondescript static mesh that we can use in this case as a button.
Okay, now we're going to want to push this button in the same way that we do with the E key.
So I'm going to add in a collision.
So I'm going to type in box, box collision.
Now I'm going to want to take this and scale it up so that it fits comfortably in front of the mesh.
Okay, that should give us enough spice.
Now again, like we did last time, I'm going to need two events.
The on component begin overlap and the on component end overlap.
Jump in and rather than rewriting all the code myself, I'm going to jump into the BP door
and I am going to highlight these three sections of the code and hold down control
and add in another. So I've got these sections.
So I've got the enable input and the player controller and the E key.
I'm going to press control C, jump across to the blueprints and press control V.
It's down and connect these up.
So we straight away got most of the code that we need here.
Now, when we press the E key, we don't actually want to be running code
on the BP underscore button. We want to be running code on the BP underscore door.
In order to do that, we're going to need a means of defining which doors belong to which buttons.
We'll do that by using a variable.
So if you come down into the variables and press plus, I'm going to call this connected doors.
And I'm going to hit the button, for instance, and I want to be able to set this per instance.
And now for variable type, I'm going to do a drop down and I am going to search for BP underscore door.
And when I scroll over, you'll see the left knob, an option for object reference.
And this is what I'm going to select.
There's one more thing that I'm going to do.
I want to be able to add more than one door to a button.
So to do this, rather than having a singular door reference, I'm going to do a drop down box and select an array.
So an array is just going to change this variable to rather than one single variable,
it's going to be a list of doors and we can add multiple entries in.
So to work with this, I'm going to drag the connected doors in.
I'm going to change to a get.
I'm going to then drag off of the connected tools and I'm going to look for a for loop.
A for each loop to be exact.
I'm going to connect that up to the execution pin.
The way a for each loop works is if you provide it with an array,
it will trigger the loop body once for each actor which is inside this array.
So this allows us to go through and perform an action for each actor.
Right. Now that we have a link to the actor here,
I'm going to want to do one thing and that is change the step.
The Boolean for is locked.
So if it is locked, it will be true and I want to change it to false.
If it's false, I want to change it to true.
So I'm going to drag off. First thing I need to do is query it.
So I'm going to do get locked and that will give me get is locked.
And I'm also going to want to set.
So I'll type set locked and go set is locked next to that up.
Now I want to reverse this value.
So I'm going to drag off and I'm going to search for or not.
So this is going to this is going to to reverse it.
If it's true, it will return false.
If it is false, it will return true.
This is great.
What we've got here is we are changing the we're changing the Boolean.
We're toggling the Boolean.
Now there's one more thing that I'd like to do.
And that is update the lights, because that way we can see if the door is locked or is unlocked.
So I'm going to drag off and I'm going to search for update light.
And this is the function that we created.
And this is a great example of why creating code in functions is a really good way to do something,
because this will this is then we can call this and we can run this at any point.
Any point that we want to make sure the lights are updated.
We can just run this function without having to go away or write the appropriate code.
So we have quite a simple straightforward script here for each connected door.
We are going to swap the variable or swap the variable over.
So it's true to false, to false to true.
And then we're going to update the lights.
So let's see this in action.
And hit compile and save.
Right. So I'm going to grab my BP dot button and drag it into the world.
Shift it up and rotate it.
I'm going to push it back a bit to make sure that it doesn't overlap with the player start.
Now with this button, you can see with it selected, we have connected doors as an input in the details.
Now I want to connect this to both the doors, so I'm going to push it twice to program two.
And you'll see now we have two entries in this array.
Now I could do a drop down, which would allow me to select a door in the nether manually.
But also I have next to it a per pent.
Now, if I click on that, it's not going to let me click on anything until I am overlapping the specific class,
which it is. So you can see here the BP, the PIC BP underscore door.
I'm going to have that as my first entry and this is my second entry.
Right. So now it's time to test.
So if I jump into the level, walk up to my sling, my shoulder,
you can see when I push the button, it is flicking between the two separate doors.
And we should now be able to see that the left hand door will open and the right hand door won't.
So it looks like a relatively simple example.
But with this, we would be able to create numerous buttons and numerous doors with overlapping functionality.
So you'd easily be able to create some kind of puzzle maze or something.
But it goes as a simple example of how we're going to animate an actor
and we can go away and control and control settings from an external.
Great. Now, one last thing before we finish.
Something that we haven't done to this point is looked at commenting.
Now, commenting is an important part of coding.
If you want to make sure that other people can understand what you've created.
It goes alongside good naming conventions for variables and functions.
We haven't shown how to do that yet.
So for example, I wanted to comment this here because this is the opening and the closing of the door.
Let me left-hand click. So I select all of them.
Then just by pressing the C key, I can make a comment.
Update door mesh rotation over time.
OK, so it's a simple comment here, but there are also some settings that I can come in here.
But if I double click, the main thing is I can change the color.
And this is really useful because you can see now from what can be just a pile of spaghetti with lots and lots of things connected.
You can now make a bit more sense out of what's going on in this case.
Great. So that is you just need to highlight something and press the C button.
So, blueprints and its functionality are all over Unreal Engine.
There's not much of the engine which can't be controlled or sort of like added to functionality wise by just knowing a little bit of blueprints.
So thank you for sticking with this tutorial.
I hope you've got some value out of it.
It should act as a good foundation if you want to go into learning more complicated blueprints.